Il est comme ça, lui.
Ah, je comprends mieux !
Tout cet attirail, ça veut dire qu’il est
sadique !
Cet adjectif, « sadique », il provient du
fameux marquis de Sade, un aventurier libertin
du XVIIIe siècle.
Dans cette vidéo, je vous propose de remonter
à la source du sadisme, la vie du scandaleux
marquis.
Je suis Romain, et vous êtes sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Comme je voulais faire une synthèse de ce
qu’est le sadisme du marquis de Sade, et
que je ne trouvais aucun article ou manuel
pouvant m’éclairer sur le sujet, j’ai
lu cette belle biographie de Maurice Lever.
Et comme le sadisme a d’abord été incarné
par le sulfureux marquis, avant d’être
théorisé dans ses écrits, je vais vous
en donner une idée…
en 10 coups de fouet !
Regardez la vidéo jusqu’au bout, parce
que les derniers vont vous étonner !
En regardant les choses d’un point de vue
déterministe, tous les ingrédients étaient
réunis pour faire du marquis de Sade un scandaleux
libertin.
Déjà, son père, le compte de Sade, était
l'un des plus brillants modèles de libertin
sous le règne de Louis XV.
Ensuite, le marquis a été arraché à sa
mère à l’âge de quatre ans.
Et puis il a été élevé en partie chez
son oncle, l’abbé de Sade…
un abbé libertin, qui faisait beaucoup rire
Voltaire en faisant voeu de chasteté alors
qu’il vivait avec deux femmes dans une forteresse,
où il faisait aussi venir des prostitués.
Enfin, le jeune marquis de Sade a également
passé du temps dans les établissements religieux,
où les châtiments corporels, l’homosexualité
et la pédophilie étaient monnaie courante
à l’époque.
Le sadisme du marquis de Sade s’explique
en partie par son mépris de classe.
Enfant, il a été élevé avec la conviction
aristocratique d'appartenir à une espèce
supérieure ; très tôt, il se croit au-dessus
des autres est autorisé à s'en servir virgule
nature despotique.
Il a également subi l'influence du comte
de Charolais, le tuteur de son premier compagnon
de jeu, Louis-Joseph de Bourbon.
Or, ce comte passait pour un des personnages
les plus sadiques de son temps : par exemple,
il s’amusait à tirer sur des gens qui passaient
simplement dans son champ de vision, ou sur
des ouvriers qui travaillaient en hauteur.
Et après, il se faisait grâcier par Louis
XV.
D’ailleurs, pour la petite anecdote, une
fois le roi lui aurait répondu ce mot sublime
:
« Monsieur, la grâce que vous demandez est
due à votre rang et à votre qualité de
prince du sang, mais je l'accorderai plus
volontiers encore à celui qui vous en fera
autant.
»
Toute sa vie, le marquis de Sade a toujours
montré beaucoup de morgue : il éprouvait
un grand mépris à l’égard de tous ceux
qui n’étaient pas de son rang, et il traitait
violemment, sans aucun égard ni reconnaissance,
les personnes qui travaillaient pour lui.
Souvenez-vous de ça pour le coup de fouet
n°7.
Le marquis de Sade était un grand passionné
de théâtre, qu’il a assidument pratiqué
au célèbre lycée Louis-le-Grand.
Et c’est très probablement ce qui explique
une particularité majeure du sadisme, sa
théâtralité.
Le marquis est le metteur en scène de ses
parties fines : il commande les postures,
focalise le plaisir sur certaines parties
du corps ; il compose les scènes, organise
les groupes, déplace et rassemble les partenaires
; il insiste pour soigner certains détails.
Quant au vrai théâtre, ce n’est que tard
dans sa vie, à partir de la cinquantaine,
qu’il essaie de faire représenter ses pièces
à Paris et en province - mais avec très
peu de succès, parce que les comités de
lecture trouvaient son travail ou trop médiocre
ou trop choquant.
Pour la petite anecdote, là où il a pu laisser
s’épanouir son talent de metteur en scène,
c’est à l’asile de Charenton, dont le
directeur, qui se prend d’affection pour
lui, est convaincu que le théâtre peut guérir
la folie.
Ce qui est assez drôle, c’est que le marquis
attribuait les rôles en fonction de la démence
: par exemple, il donne à un malade convaincu
d’être l’homme le plus riche du monde
le rôle d’un grand banquier - mais le problème,
c’est que ça aggrave la folie !
Le marquis de Sade est totalement athée,
et il d’ailleurs rédigé et prononcé des
discours enflammés à propos de sa conviction
lors de la Révolution française.
À nouveau, je vous invite encore à retenir
ce point pour le septième coup de fouet.
De son point de vue, toute divinité est simplement
une stupide illusion qui inspire des cérémonies
grotesques.
C’est pour ça que, sur le plan du plaisir,
le blasphème provoque chez lui une grande
jouissance - au point qu’il dit qu’il
faudrait inventer Dieu s’il n’existait
pas, pour qu’il puisse avoir le plaisir
de l’insulter.
C’est d’ailleurs cet aspect qui est à
l’origine du premier grand scandale, l’affaire
d’Arcueil en 1768.
Il aurait séquestré et fouetté jusqu’au
sang une mendiante ; mais surtout, comme c’était
le dimanche de Pâques, il l’aurait obligée
à se confesser à lui pendant qu’il la
flagellait.
Cependant, il n’est pas certain que les
choses se soient exactement passées comme
ça.
C’est ce premier scandale, l’affaire d’Arcueil,
qui a créé la légende, reprise est amplifiée
jusque par la presse étrangère.
Or, comme on peut l’imaginer, même si le
marquis était tout sauf un enfant de coeur,
ses actes n’ont pas échappé à aux phénomènes
de la rumeur et du téléphone arabe.
En fait, Sade était loin d’être le seul
aristocrate à profiter de son statut, de
son ascendant social, et de son aisance financière
pour infliger des sévices à des individus
du peuple particulièrement fragilisés, comme
des prostituées ou des orphelins.
Mais plusieurs facteurs étaient réunis pour
transformer un fait divers somme toute banal
pour l’époque en un scandale public.
Tout d’abord, on est vingt ans avant la
Révolution, et, l'opinion publique est lassée
de voir la justice épargner les nobles pour
les sévices sexuels.
Ensuite, les mentalités sont encore très
religieuses, et la dimension blasphématoire
de l’affaire d’Arcueil ne peut qu’en
décupler le scandale.
Mais aussi, le marquis avait de puissants
ennemis qu’il devait à son affiliation
à la maison de Condé, une branche des Bourbons.
Et inversement, Sade n’avait quasiment pas
d’amis ; il organisait ses parties fines
quasiment pour lui seul ; et plus généralement,
il avait vraiment négligé son réseau personnel
(comme son père d’ailleurs).
Tous ces facteurs laissent à penser que les
crimes du marquis ont probablement été exagérés,
qu’il était un peu le bouc émissaire du
peuple et de la presse, en tant qu’incarnation
de la corruption de la noblesse.
Mais bon, il faut voir aussi la responsabilité
du marquis.
Ce qui m’a marqué, de manière globale,
dans cette biographie, c’est la profonde
insouciance du marquis - et ça à tous les
plans.
C’est vrai, tout d’abord, de son libertinage
: comme je l’ai déjà dit, Sade fréquentait
les prostituées et organisait des soirées
au vu et au su de tout le monde ; il avait
plusieurs lieux dévolus à ses plaisirs personnels
; la police des moeurs, la bonne société,
et sa belle-famille, tout le monde était
au courant.
Ensuite, c’était d’autant plus ostensible
que ça lui coûtait vraiment un bras.
Comme beaucoup de nobles de son époque, le
marquis dépensait sans compter, faisait systématiquement
des dettes à droite à gauche.
À part harceler son notaire pour qu’il
lui envoie toujours plus d’argent toujours
plus vite, il était indifférent à sa situation
financière, si bien qu’il a fini totalement
ruiné, en ayant mangé une bonne partie de
l’héritage de ses enfants.
Enfin, il était aussi insouciant sur le plan
judiciaire : alors même que sa belle-famille
avait remué ciel et terre pour sauver sa
réputation - et surtout la leur - et lui
éviter la prison, voire l’exécution, il
recommençait de plus belle ses orgies.
Comme les drogués, il promet, il se calme
un moment, puis il retombe dans l’abîme
de son addiction.
À la fin, sa belle-famille en a eu tellement
marre que c’est elle qui a insisté auprès
du pouvoir pour que le marquis soit gardé
entre quatre murs, là où il pourrait faire
le moins de mal possible.
Mais voilà, les événements ont écourté
sa détention.
Le marquis est exfiltré vers une autre prison
une dizaine de jours avant la prise de la
Bastille le 14 juillet, et grâce à l’exaspération
de la population à l'égard des détentions
arbitraires, il est libéré début avril
1790.
Et c’est là, en pleine Révolution française,
que commence un autre chapitre de la légende,
mais pour le coup totalement fictif.
Pour faire court, le marquis est passé à
la postérité comme un révolutionnaire de
premier plan, l’incarnation des victimes
de l’arbitraire monarchique et de l’esprit
de liberté et d'égalité qui soufflait alors
sur la France.
Et là, rappelez-vous du deuxième coup de
fouet, son mépris de classe.
C’est vrai que le marquis a pris part aux
événements, qu’il a été un « citoyen
» très actif, mais ce que les recherches
pointues du biographe révèlent, c’est
qu’il l’a fait purement et simplement
par opportunisme.
Déjà, il a caché ses origines, changé
son nom, supprimé sa particule, et il se
faisait passer pour un homme de lettres sans
le sou.
Ensuite, il était très actif en sous-main
pour protéger son patrimoine des violences
révolutionnaires.
Enfin, qui peut croire une seconde qu’il
souscrivait à l’idéal de l'égalité,
lui l’aristocrate si attaché à son rang
et par nature si méprisant à l’égard
du peuple ?
La supercherie aurait pu durer longtemps,
mais très paradoxalement, le marquis a perdu
son crédit auprès de sa section révolutionnaire...
en refusant d’avaliser une condamnation
à mort !
C’est étonnant, mais Sade fut le premier
écrivain français à s’insurger contre
la peine de mort.
C’était inévitable étant donné son insouciance
: Sade a passé un tiers de sa vie entre quatre
murs.
Et à lire sa biographie, j’ai l’impression
que c’est cet enfermement qui a permis la
traduction de son expérience de libertin
en une oeuvre littéraire.
Alors certes, le marquis s’était très
tôt passionné pour la littérature, mais
pour ce qui est de l'écriture il était d’abord
attiré plutôt vers des oeuvres historiques,
ou des récits de voyage (par exemple, à
partir de son exil forcé en Italie pour échapper
à la justice française).
En prison, le personnel est plutôt laxiste
à son égard, mais il ne peut bien sûr plus
organiser les orgies dont il a le secret.
Il se masturbe comme on fume des cigarettes,
il a quelques rapports sexuels, mais c’est
loin de pouvoir satisfaire ses goûts extrêmes.
Alors il donne libre cours à son imagination
sur le papier : il écrit, il produit à un
rythme impressionnant en s’inspirant de
ses orgies, il y mélange des considérations
philosophiques
Ses premiers livres ne lui permettent pas
de vivre de sa plume comme il l’espérait,
mais ils connaissent un certain succès dû
à leur teneur en transgression.
De libertin scandaleux, le marquis de Sade
devient écrivain maudit.
C'est la publication de Justine, son oeuvre
emblématique, en 1791, en qui a fait de « sadien
» une épithète maudite, symbole du mal
absolu.
Les écrits du marquis sont si choquants qu’ils
sont mis à l’index dès que la censure
se resserre, et forcément cette interdiction
accroit aussi leur notoriété.
Et comme Sade a assez goûté de la prison,
ses oeuvres sont publiées anonymement et
il nie farouchement en être l'auteur, allant
même jusqu’à les condamner fermement par
écrit !
En même temps, c’était peut-être plus
sage.
En effet, la particularité de l’oeuvre
de Sade, c’est qu’elle ne relève même
pas de la pornographie tant l’invraisemblance
de son extrémisme tue l’excitation.
On est plus proche de l’horreur que de l’érotisme
- d’ailleurs la vie de Sade a inspiré des
films d’horreur.
Napoléon, qui détestait Sade, a qualifié
Justine de « livre le plus abominable qu’ait
enfanté l’imagination la plus dépravée
».
L’oeuvre du marquis ne se résume pas à
des récits dignes de films d'horreur, car
il en ressort aussi une certaine philosophie
- et plus particulièrement une certaine morale.
Sade a notamment théorisé « l’isolisme
», ce qui est d’ailleurs un terme de son
invention.
« L’isolisme », c’est l’idée selon
laquelle autrui ne serait qu’un instrument,
aussi bien dans le désir sexuel que dans
la relation sociale.
Du coup, tout est permis, parce qu’il ne
faut ressentir aucune empathie, puisque la
souffrance d’autrui est totalement dépourvue
de valeur pour le sujet.
D’un côté, cette théorie est un peu contradictoire
avec l’apologie sadienne de la liberté
- pour que je sois libre, ma liberté doit
forcément être bornée par celle d’autrui,
et réciproquement - mais le marquis a bien
mis en pratique l’isolisme dans sa vie,
ou plutôt il a bien théorisé son propre
comportement.
Il se plaisait à terroriser les femmes qui
étaient ses victimes ; il traitait comme
des chiens son personnel et ses intendants,
avec une méchanceté naturelle et en s’affranchissant
de tout principe moral.
Il était d’un égoïsme assumé incroyable,
méprisait, mentait, trahissait, etc. - rien
ne l’arrêtait.
Bref, vous l’avez compris, on ne peut vraiment
pas reprocher au marquis de Sade l’incohérence
des paroles et des actes.
Je n’ai pas trop pour habitude de donner
mon avis, mais je dois dire qu’à la lecture
de cette biographie, Sade m’apparaît comme
une VRAIE RACLURE.
Pour ma part, je ne dirai pas le « génial
marquis », je ne suis pas du tout fan, je
ne suis pas béat d’admiration devant la
vie, certes romanesque, de l’aventurier
libertin.
Parce qu’il faut quand même le dire, les
légendes « Sade le révolutionnaire », ou
« Sade le libérateur des moeurs », c’est
du pipeau.
Sur le plan des faits, la liberté de Sade,
c’est la liberté du tortionnaire.
La philosophie politique de Sade, s’il y
en a une, c’est l’inégalité radicale
des castes, avec l’élite qui est autorisée
à se servir en toute impunité des hommes
inférieurs comme de purs objets.
Enfin, au point de vue moral, le marquis a
quand même incarné dans son comportement
quotidien - à en croire tous les témoignages
regroupés dans cette biographie - l’égoïsme,
la malhonnêteté et la méchanceté, même,
et peut-être surtout à l’égard de ses
collaborateurs, de ses meilleurs amis, de
sa famille, et de ses enfants.
Bref, c’était une lecture agréable et
intéressante, mais certainement pas inspirante
pour moi.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, mettez un pouce
bleu et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire l’article de blog tiré de ma
lecture, ou ma synthèse sur le sadisme qui
sont sur le site 1000 idées de culture générale,
voire pour pour lire cette biographie, tous
les liens sont dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisées dans le format le
plus clair possible, vous pouvez vous inscrire
à la newsletter en laissant votre adresse
e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain et sous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous vous n’avez pas besoin d’être
masochiste pour vous intéresser au meilleur
de la pensée.